[Musique]
on vous propose une formation de
palefrenier soigneur donc c'est un ca
paie donc un diplôme national délivré
par le ministère de l'agriculture le
palefrenier c'est le le professionnel
qui s'occupe des écuries et des chevaux
donc il est autant chargés de la
maintenance des installations de la
tenue de l'établissement au niveau de la
propreté que des soins aux animaux
chez nous elle se fait en apprentissage
donc c'est une formation initiale et
donc elle se fait sur un ou deux ans la
plupart du temps deux ans mais on a
aussi des jeunes qui ont d'abord fait un
autre c ap ou qui ont été au lycée et
qui de ce fait sont dispensés des
matières générales
on est sur une alternance à peu près
d'une semaine en formation deux semaines
en entreprise
principalement des collégiens ou jeunes
lycéens voilà puisqu'on est sur un
niveau 3 donc on est sur un petit niveau
de formation
donc on est plutôt sur ma premier niveau
de qualification donc au des jeunes
entre 15 et 18 ans et qui sortent du
système scolaire pour entrer dans
l'apprentissage dans le monde du travail
[Musique]
la passion des animaux mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut être capable de confronter sa
passion son envie à une réalité qui est
quand même difficile